please welcome drew barrymore
[Applause]
oh my god it's real welcome to the true
barrymore show
it's monday my favorite day
because we're here to rebrand mondays
boy did they get the
short end of the deal we love mondays
around here because after obsessing over
the weekend about
all the things you need to do i say
mondays
it's the day to get her done and look
ahead to
all the great things that you can do
this week
my heart's beating okay now
allow me to reintroduce myself
you may think you know me and you do
i am who you think i am but i'm also
someone who is learning
all the time and i'm so excited to
figure out this thing called
life with you i believe in the
collective experience and for my entire
life
i've been interacting with people and
that's exactly what i want to do on this
show
this is all for you
it's true as it says in the opening of
our show
we're gonna learn laugh cry cook heal
all of it and i'm committed to putting
all
aspects of life into this show every day
now here we are in this studio we have
our fantastic crew
i love you guys so much
and look in some ways you're the
physical audience
and you'll be hearing them throughout
our show and hearing their wonderful
cacophony
bringing the life and energy to this
room
no pressure and we also have our virtual
friends
hello look at these humans
in this brand new technology but
technology aside
we found a new way to have that
collective experience from people
with all over for all over the country
see it's live whoops
so we'll see you guys throughout the
show
and to everyone else in my personal life
thank you for watching today i love you
and to my two daughters olive and
frankie
everything all of it is always just for
you
so let's get started everyone and the
way we're gonna start each show is a
segment called
drew's news
[Applause]
excuse me sir ma'am guy
tell me your story
ma'am i asked you a question
this is drew's news
this is true's news it's drew's news
at this desk we're going to curate
all kinds of stories for you i am a news
and pop culture junkie i
love good news i also like odd or unique
happenings that make me laugh
i love hearing about trends and hot
topics
i like to seek out the stories that may
be a little harder to find but are
totally life affirming and necessary
to hear because we all need to know it's
going to be okay
so consider me your human scrapbook full
of stories both
big small and everything in between
oh right our first story is personal to
us
tonight the empire state building is
lighting up in our signature yellow in
honor of our big premiere
and even though i'm a cali girl at heart
and i'm thinking of all of you west
coasters during these fires
new york is now my adopted home and this
honor means so much to us
thank you new york now let's see what
made the papers
okay oh i love this story because it
made her story
this year for the first time three moms
made it to the corner finals
serena williams uh spatana parochova
and victoria as rankova i might have
messed that up
and if so i am so sorry the winner was
actually
naomi osaka and i really just wanted to
give it up to all these incredible women
shine a light on you as everyone is
doing and celebrate you
right along everybody else thank you for
all that you're doing and inspiring
all of us moms our third story
cnn reports that a 62 year old ball
python has laid
seven eggs even though
she hasn't been near a male snake in
over two decades
is she 62 or 16
sneaking out for a little fun uh-huh
this story resonates with me because i
haven't been in captivity with a male
for quite some time either
i have my two daughters and my cup
runneth over if you know what i mean i'm
good
however when i usually fill out medical
forms and they ask is there a
possibility you're pregnant
pregnant i'm usually like a chance
but now she's making me rethink and get
scared and curious and wonder
listen this mama python she got it done
and although it is certainly suspicious
how i say
live your bliss
and finally this one got me so excited
because i love
board games i mean literally this is my
game closet there's
no joke there and toy book magazine
reports that hasbro is making a guess
who
hometown helpers edition a version of
the game with characters like
firefighter and teacher mail care
mail carrier and more hasbro is also
donating 10
per game sold to community charities
does your person have glasses and save
lives
yes one more story that i don't want to
miss
actually we've got two minutes to crush
oh my gosh how did this happen
okay so here we are it's our very first
show
and i am nervous i'm excited
um we're live in certain places so if i
mess
up well you know what that's just gonna
happen and all i can say
is i am so excited that we are here for
day one
and we'll be right back with more
you